This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. From high school football coaches to career counsellors, professional advice givers often have a simple mantra. Look within. You have the answers you've been searching for. Ask yourself the important questions and then listen to your inner voice. Such advice is especially common in countries with individualistic cultures,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。从高中橄榄球教练到职业咨询师，专业的建议者们通常都有一个简单的口头禅：向内看。你拥有你一直在寻找的答案。问自己重要的问题，然后倾听你内心的声音。这种建议在个人主义文化的国家尤为常见，
such as the United States. We believe our answers have to come from within, because each of us is a unique individual on our own special journey. We celebrate the idea of marching to our own drummer, with disparaged people who follow the herd. journey. We celebrate the idea of marching to our own drummer, with the sparrage people who follow the herd. In recent years, however, a variety of psychological research experiments have raised serious questions about how well we know ourselves.
例如美国。我们相信答案必须来自内心，因为我们每个人都是在自己特殊旅程中独一无二的个体。我们推崇走自己的路，并鄙视那些随波逐流的人。然而近年来，各种心理学研究实验对我们了解自己的程度提出了严重的质疑。
Some of these experiments raise profound questions about how well we can know ourselves. This is the second installment of our annual series, YouTube.0, where we try to answer some of life's most profound questions with wisdom and compassion. Last week, we considered how we can take advantage of our capacity for rumination. This week on Hidden Brain we ask is the best path forward to look within or without? Every day throughout our lives we have to make decisions big and small. We have to decide what to eat, whom to hang out with, when to call it quits on a job that's gone sour. We have a simple way to confront these choices. We ask ourselves what we should do. This process is so routine and automatic that most of us
其中一些实验对我们了解自己的程度提出了深刻的疑问。这是我们年度系列节目“YouTube.0”的第二期，我们试图用智慧和同情心来回答生活中一些最深刻的问题。上周，我们探讨了如何利用我们的反刍能力。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨：最好的前进道路是向内看还是向外看？我们一生中每天都要做大大小小的决定。我们必须决定吃什么、和谁交往、何时辞掉一份变质的工作。我们有一种简单的方法来面对这些选择：问自己应该做什么。这个过程如此常规且自动，以至于我们大多数人
never stop to ask, is there a better way? At the University of Virginia, psychologists Tim Wilson thinks long and hard about staff most of us don't think much about. One area that has fascinated him is how we decide what's best for us and how we ought to be going about it. Tim Wilson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Great to be here, Shankar. Thanks for about it. Tim Wilson, welcome to Hidden Brain. Great to be here, Sean Carter. Thanks for inviting me. Tim, I want to start with some examples from your own life on how people make choices. A friend of yours whom you call Susan was in a relationship with a guy named Stephen. Both names are pseudonyms. How did Susan describe
从未停下来问过：有没有更好的方法？在弗吉尼亚大学，心理学家蒂姆·威尔逊对我们大多数人不太思考的事情进行了深入的思考。他感兴趣的一个领域是，我们如何决定什么对我们最好，以及我们应该如何去做。蒂姆·威尔逊，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。谢谢你的邀请。蒂姆，我想从你生活中关于人们如何做选择的一些例子开始。你的一位朋友，你称她为苏珊，曾与一个叫斯蒂芬的人交往。这两个名字都是化名。苏珊是怎么向你描述
Stephen to you? Well, see, was in a relationship with him for well over a year. And was convinced that she was in love with him, that he was a perfect match for her. He kind of checked off all the boxes of what she was looking for. He was a really nice guy, sweet and kind. They were both social workers. The only problem was that for those of us who knew them, it didn't bring true. We weren't convinced this isn't really felt the way she said she
斯蒂芬的？嗯，她和他交往了一年多，确信自己爱上了他，认为他是她的完美伴侣。他几乎满足了她所寻找的所有条件。他是个非常好的人，既贴心又善良。他们都是社会工作者。唯一的问题是，对于我们这些了解他们的人来说，这感觉并不真实。我们并不相信她真的像她说的那样
did. And she would sometimes seem to make excuses not to see him on weekends and she just wasn't acting the way someone who is in love, deeply in love with someone typically would act, or in fact how she had acted in some previous relationships. Sometime later, the relationship came to an end. Tim didn't tell Susan, I told you so. That's partly because he's a nice guy, but it's also because while he had misgivings about Susan's relationship, he never actually confided his concerns to her. I have to say, I just didn't feel it was my place to sort of puncture the book. I kind of wanted to, but I didn't think she would be terribly receptive to it. As most of us wouldn't to hear someone tell us that we didn't know what we're doing.
有那种感觉。她有时似乎会找借口周末不见他，她的行为举止并不像一个深陷爱河的人通常会有的样子，事实上，这与她在之前几段感情中的表现也不一样。后来，这段关系结束了。蒂姆没有对苏珊说“我早就告诉过你”。这部分是因为他是个好人，但也因为虽然他对苏珊的感情有疑虑，但他从未真正向她吐露过。我必须说，我只是觉得我不该去戳破这个泡沫。我其实想过，但我认为她不会太乐意听。就像我们大多数人都不愿意听到别人告诉我们，我们不知道自己在做什么一样。
There have been other times Tim has picked up things about his friends that they didn't seem to perceive themselves. One glaring example, a friend who claimed to be a social introvert. Mike has always referred to himself as being shy and introverted, which is quite surprising to those of us who know him because he seems anything but, he's quite gregarious and can be in a circle of people at a party
蒂姆还有其他几次发现朋友们身上的一些特质，而他们自己似乎并没有察觉。一个明显的例子是，一位朋友声称自己是个社交内向者。迈克一直称自己害羞且内向，这让我们这些了解他的人感到非常惊讶，因为他看起来一点也不内向，他非常合群，可以在聚会上融入人群，
and be telling funny stories and seems quite at ease in social situations and doesn't seem introverted at all. I want to look at a third example in your own life about the mismatch between how people perceive themselves and how others perceive them. You know of a couple, both of them psychologists, in fact, who told you they were house hunting. What kind of a home were they looking for to? I have to chalk out this story because in order to figure out which house to buy, they decided to use their professional training and use the proverbial seven point scale to rate every aspect of every house.
讲着有趣的故事，在社交场合显得非常自在，一点也不内向。我想看看你生活中关于人们如何看待自己与他人如何看待他们之间不匹配的第三个例子。你认识一对夫妇，事实上他们都是心理学家，他们告诉你他们正在找房子。他们想找什么样的房子？我必须讲讲这个故事，因为为了弄清楚买哪套房子，他们决定利用他们的专业训练，使用众所周知的七分量表来评估每套房子的每一个方面。
On a seven point scale, how good is the layout? How good is the broom closet? How good is the vocation? Aggregate all these data at the end and compute what the best house was for them. Well, so they're credit. They realize after a few houses, this was ridiculous. And if anything, confuse them more than clarified which house they wanted. So they finally abandoned the seven point scale. Now, you also have the opportunity to observe people who are experts in dealing with others. And one of them is a real estate agent, Nancy Caperton.
在七分量表上，布局有多好？扫帚柜有多好？位置有多好？最后汇总所有这些数据，计算出哪套房子最适合他们。好吧，值得称赞的是，看了几套房子后，他们意识到这太荒谬了。如果说有什么影响的话，那就是这让他们更加困惑，而不是明确了他们想要哪套房子。所以他们最终放弃了七分量表。现在，你也有机会观察那些擅长与人打交道的人。其中一位是房地产经纪人，南希·卡珀顿。
Does she indulge people like your friends who have detailed wish lists for their homes? Well, Nancy was our real estate agent. My wife's in mine. I grabbed Nancy. She was so smart and insightful. She would, in her first meeting with clients, sit down with them and ask them a detail what they were looking for and listen carefully. And she told me this later that she would then ignore everything they said. She just didn't trust that people knew themselves with it.
她会迁就像你朋友那样对房子有详细愿望清单的人吗？嗯，南希是我们的房地产经纪人，也是我妻子的。我找了南希。她非常聪明且有洞察力。她在第一次与客户见面时，会坐下来详细询问他们的需求并仔细倾听。后来她告诉我，她随后会忽略他们所说的一切。她只是不相信人们真正了解自己。
I said, she just didn't trust that people knew themselves with it. Why? So what she do is take them to a variety of houses, some in town, some out of town, some with big yards, some with small yards, some old, some new. And she would watch very carefully for their emotional reactions when they looked at the house and try to deduce how people felt. And she often felt, and I think probably rightfully so, that she would discover what people wanted more than they knew, and people in fact often bought houses that had nothing to do with their original wish-rest.
我说，她只是不相信人们真正了解自己。为什么？所以她会带他们去看各种各样的房子，有的在城里，有的在城外，有的带大院子，有的带小院子，有的旧，有的新。她会非常仔细地观察他们看房时的情绪反应，并试图推断人们的感受。她经常觉得，而且我认为可能确实如此，她能比他们自己更早发现他们想要什么，事实上，人们经常买的房子与他们最初的愿望清单毫无关系。
You give me some examples of friends who fail to understand important things about their own preferences, important things about themselves. But you have evidence that the same thing might also be true of yourself. Your daughter recently demonstrated an understanding of you that was greater than your own self understanding, and it had to do with some plans you had for relan skipping your lawn. Tell me that story to him. Yeah, my wife and I are doing a construction in our backyard. We're building a screened pavilion in our backyard.
你给了我一些朋友未能理解自己偏好、未能理解自身重要事情的例子。但你有证据表明同样的情况也可能发生在你身上。你的女儿最近表现出对你的理解比你自己的自我理解还要深刻，这与你计划重新规划草坪有关。讲讲那个故事吧，蒂姆。是的，我和我妻子正在后院进行施工。我们正在后院建一个带纱窗的凉亭。
But what this meant is it would cover a small gardening plant that I've had for years, where I would grow a few tomato plants and a few other things. And I told my daughter that this was our plant and it was going to be great. And she said to me, you know, over the years you've enjoyed that little vegetable plant so much. Why are you giving that up? That's ridiculous. And I realized she was right. And we made part of the plan to move my garden plot to our front yard. So I now have thriving tomato plants in my front yard
但这意味着它会覆盖我多年来一直拥有的一小块菜地，我在那里种了几株西红柿和其他一些东西。我告诉女儿这是我们的计划，这会很棒。她对我说，你知道，多年来你一直很享受那小块菜地。你为什么要放弃它？这太荒谬了。我意识到她是正确的。于是我们将移动我的菜地到前院作为计划的一部分。所以现在我的前院里长满了茂盛的西红柿，
and enjoying it more than I imagined. It's the most self-evident idea in the world. When we want to know how we feel and what we want, we ask ourselves, how do I feel? What do I want? But as Tim started to see gaps between what his friends said they wanted and what actually made them happy, he began to run experiments to explore the underlying psychological question. How well do we really know ourselves? When we come back, the obstacles to self-knowledge and the surprising path around them. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
而且我享受它的程度超出了我的想象。这是世界上最显而易见的道理。当我们想知道自己的感受和想要什么时，我们会问自己：我感觉如何？我想要什么？但当蒂姆开始看到朋友们所说的想要的东西与真正让他们快乐的东西之间的差距时，他开始进行实验来探索潜在的心理学问题：我们到底有多了解自己？当我们回来时，我们将探讨自我认知的障碍以及绕过它们的惊人路径。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Tim Wilson studies the curious gaps between what we think will make us happy and what actually makes us happy. Between the people we think we are and the people we actually are. At a deeper level he studies the nature of self-knowledge and the obstacles to achieving it. Tim, you run experiments where you ask people to analyze their own attitudes. What kind of attitudes have volunteers in your studies talked about? We've had them think about a variety of things, such as how they feel about a romantic relationship they're involved in, and we ask them to make a list of all the reasons why
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家蒂姆·威尔逊研究了我们认为会让我们快乐的事物与实际让我们快乐的事物之间的奇妙差距，以及我们认为自己是谁与我们实际是谁之间的差距。在更深层次上，他研究了自我认知的本质以及实现它的障碍。蒂姆，你进行了一些实验，要求人们分析自己的态度。你的研究中的志愿者谈论过什么样的态度？我们让他们思考各种各样的事情，比如他们对自己所处的恋爱关系的感受，我们要求他们列出所有导致
it's going the way it is. So give us the pluses and minuses. Tim has asked other volunteers about political candidates they support, about hot button issues and the news, even about works of art. The volunteers have shared a range of opinions as you might expect. But when Tim and his colleagues have asked them why they have the opinions they do, no one has ever, ever given Tim one particular answer. No one ever says, I have no idea. That has been striking. So, you know, we've asked people in that question in lots of studies, hundreds of participants. And I don't remember anyone ever saying,
现状的原因。所以，列出优点和缺点。蒂姆还询问了其他志愿者关于他们支持的政治候选人、新闻中的热门话题，甚至是艺术作品的看法。正如你所料，志愿者们分享了一系列观点。但当蒂姆和他的同事问他们为什么会有这些观点时，从来没有人给过蒂姆一个特定的答案。从来没有人说：“我不知道。”这令人震惊。所以，你知道，我们在很多研究中问过人们这个问题，有数百名参与者。我不记得有人说过，
I don't know. They come up with reasons pretty easily. So one possibility, of course, is that when people tell you very confidently why they have the opinions they do, it's because they actually understand themselves well and they're just telling you, here's why I believe what I believe. But there's been some interesting studies of people who have some neurological problems related to memory, and these people in fact do not have an accurate recollection of why they did certain things,
“我不知道。”他们很容易就能想出理由。所以，一种可能性当然是，当人们非常自信地告诉你他们为什么持有这些观点时，是因为他们确实很了解自己，他们只是在告诉你：这就是我为什么相信我所相信的。但有一些关于神经记忆相关问题的有趣研究，这些人实际上对他们为什么做某些事情没有准确的记忆，
and yet when we ask them questions, when researchers ask them questions about their actions, what did they say to? Yes, I mean, there are some fascinating case studies where people who have lost the ability to make short-term memories really have no idea why they're in the particular situation they are, but they quite freely give explanations. They spin stories, they come up with a rationale. Oliver Sacks talks about a particular patient who would, with great facility, say, oh, you must be a doctor because you're wearing a white lap coat, and I guess you're here to examine me or, no, maybe you're the butcher from down the street. And every five minutes, he would lose track of what had happened
然而当我们问他们问题时，当研究人员问他们关于行为的问题时，他们说了什么？是的，我的意思是，有一些引人入胜的案例研究，那些失去了形成短期记忆能力的人，确实不知道他们为什么处于特定的情况中，但他们却非常自由地给出解释。他们编造故事，想出理由。奥利弗·萨克斯谈到过一位特殊的病人，他会非常熟练地说：“哦，你一定是医生，因为你穿着白大褂，我想你是来给我检查的，或者，不，也许你是街那头的屠夫。”每五分钟，他就会忘记刚才发生了什么，
previously, but nonetheless, he was able to come up with a story to explain his situation. And Saks reports that this patient didn't even know he had a deficit, that he was so good at explaining his current situation, that he didn't even know he had a problem. current situation that he didn't even know he had a problem. So what we see in this instance is someone basically actually having gaps in self-knowledge, but almost seamlessly filling in those gaps to persuade himself or herself that the stories were actually true.
但尽管如此，他还是能编出一个故事来解释自己的处境。萨克斯报告说，这位病人甚至不知道自己有缺陷，他非常擅长解释自己当前的处境，以至于他甚至不知道自己有问题。所以我们在这种情况下看到的是，有人实际上存在自我认知的空白，但几乎天衣无缝地填补了这些空白，以说服自己这些故事确实是真的。
Yes, you know, it's just fascinating how easily people can convince themselves that they know what they're doing even when we know they don't. Now, some people might say these confabulations might be true of people who have neurological disorders or brain damage or psychiatric conditions. It doesn't describe me. One of your favorite studies was carried out by a group of researchers in Sweden. Tell me what they did to him.
是的，你知道，人们能如此轻易地说服自己他们知道自己在做什么，即使我们知道他们并不知道，这真是太迷人了。现在，有些人可能会说这些虚构可能只适用于患有神经系统疾病、脑损伤或精神疾病的人。这并不描述我。你最喜欢的实验之一是由瑞典的一组研究人员进行的。告诉我是怎么回事，蒂姆。
Yeah, just a fascinating study. They presented participants with two photographs of two different women on each trial. And they simply asked participants, pick the one that you think is most attractive. And they would also ask them, could you tell me why you picked the one you did? And people would say, oh, well, that woman, she had particularly pretty eyes or whatever. Well, I'm enough to the participant on some trials,
是的，这真是一项引人入胜的研究。他们在每次试验中向参与者展示两张不同女性的照片。他们只是简单地要求参与者：选出你认为最漂亮的那一张。他们还会问他们：你能告诉我为什么选这一张吗？人们会说：哦，嗯，那个女人，她有特别漂亮的眼睛，或者诸如此类的。好吧，在某些试验中，
they would show people the picture they actually had not chosen and pretended it's the one they had. So they would say people chose picture A on a particular trial instead of B. The researcher would pick up picture B, show it to the participant and say, well, tell me why you chose this one. Now, the first remarkable thing was that people didn't detect
他们会向参与者展示他们实际上并没有选择的那张照片，并假装那是他们选的。所以他们会说参与者在某次试验中选择了照片A而不是B。研究人员会拿起照片B，展示给参与者看，并说：好吧，告诉我为什么你选了这一张。现在，第一个显著的事实是，人们在大多数时候并没有察觉到
the subterfuge on most of the time. I think only about a quarter of the time did they realize that the experimenter had switched the pictures. But even more remarkable, they quite easily explained the reasons why they had chosen this particular picture, even though it's not the one they chose. They quite easily said always because of her eyes, her hair, or whatever.
这种诡计。我想只有大约四分之一的时间他们意识到实验者调换了照片。但更引人注目的是，他们非常容易地解释了为什么选择这张照片的原因，即使这不是他们选择的那张。他们非常容易地说：哦，是因为她的眼睛，她的头发，或者其他什么。
And the researchers went to some lengths to try to see, is there a difference in the reasons people give for the wrong picture compared to the reasons they give for the right picture? And they couldn't find any differences. They weren't of different length and different detail, different content. As if people could just kind of make up an explanation, even when we know in this case it was for something they hadn't actually chosen. In one case there was a male participant who was shown a picture that he hadn't chosen and he says that the woman in the picture she's radiant, I would rather have approached her in a bar than
研究人员费尽心思试图观察，人们对错误照片给出的理由与对正确照片给出的理由是否有区别？他们找不到任何区别。它们在长度、细节、内容上都没有差异。就好像人们可以随口编造一个解释，即使我们知道在这种情况下，这是针对他们实际上并没有选择的东西。有一个案例，一名男性参与者被展示了一张他没有选择的照片，他说照片里的女人很光彩照人，我宁愿在酒吧里接近她，而不是
the other one. I like earrings, even though he initially found the other woman who was not wearing earrings more attractive. It's kind of remarkable not just that people were willing to go along with the replacement photograph that the researchers picked, but were effortlessly coming up with explanations for why they in fact had picked the picture that they didn't pick. Yes, yes. And you know, it makes you wonder about how much we're confabulating, even when we're explaining our real choices.
另一个。我喜欢耳环，尽管他最初觉得那个没戴耳环的女人更吸引人。令人惊奇的不仅是人们愿意接受研究人员挑选的替换照片，而且还毫不费力地为他们实际上并没有选择那张照片给出了理由。是的，是的。而且你知道，这让你怀疑我们到底在虚构多少，即使是在解释我们真正的选择时。
So when most of us ask ourselves how we think about something, you know, we introspect, we look inward and studies like this make, make you wonder how useful is introspection. Well, let me say, Shankar, that I, I don't mean to imply that introspection is always wrong. It's not like we're totally close to why we're doing what we're doing. Of course, we have a great deal of knowledge about ourselves, but it certainly can go wrong. And, you know, in my research I've shown this particularly when you ask people to give a lot of reasons that they can sometimes mislead themselves.
所以，当我们大多数人问自己如何看待某事时，你知道，我们进行内省，我们向内看，而像这样的研究让你怀疑内省到底有多大用处。好吧，让我说，尚卡尔，我并不是暗示内省总是错的。并不是说我们完全不知道自己为什么做我们正在做的事情。当然，我们对自己有很多了解，但它确实可能出错。而且，你知道，在我的研究中，我展示了这一点，特别是当你要求人们给出很多理由时，他们有时会误导自己。
I want to stop here to underscore the irony. Many of us think that the more rational and deliberate we can be in our decision-making, the better. Surely we think the person who is asked to come up with a list of reasons for her decision will be happier with the decision because she has arrived at her conclusion deliberately and thoughtfully. Tim has found the opposite is true. We've done a lot of studies where we the opposite is true. We've done a lot of studies where we ask people simply to write down privately and anonymously why they feel the way they do about something. In some studies, it was a dating partner
我想在这里停下来强调这种讽刺。我们许多人认为，我们在决策中越理性、越深思熟虑越好。我们肯定认为，被要求列出决策理由的人会对决定更满意，因为她是经过深思熟虑才得出结论的。蒂姆发现事实恰恰相反。我们做了很多研究，我们
and some, it was food items like strawberry jams. And then there'd be a control group of randomly assigned participants who told us how they felt without first giving reasons. And the question was, which group made wiser decisions or had new best how they felt? Common wisdom is that, well, it's the people who made the list of presses and linuses that this is a wise way to make a decision or analyze our feelings. But we've often found the opposite, the people who give detailed reasons, particularly for things that are hard to explain like a romantic partner, they mislead themselves. I end up, you know, things come to mind that maybe didn't match their actual feelings, but they convince themselves
要求人们私下且匿名地写下他们对某事的感觉。在一些研究中，对象是约会对象，在一些研究中，是草莓酱之类的食品。然后会有一个随机分配的对照组，他们在不先给出理由的情况下告诉我们他们的感受。问题是，哪一组做出了更明智的决定，或者更了解自己的感受？常识是，嗯，是那些列出优缺点清单的人，这是一种明智的决策或分析感受的方法。但我们经常发现事实恰恰相反，那些给出详细理由的人，特别是对于像恋爱伴侣这样难以解释的事情，他们误导了自己。我最终，你知道，想到了可能与他们实际感受不符的事情，但他们说服了自己，
that, oh, that must be how I really felt. I just thought about that time my partner did some really annoying thing. Maybe things aren't going as well as I thought they were. So, that proverbial list of pluses and minuses aren't always a great thing to do. In another experiment, you asked people to pick one of two art posters that were on display and allowed them to take home their chosen poster, but for half the volunteers you just left it at that, but for the other half you asked them to analyze why they chose the poster they did, and then three weeks later you surveyed all the people who took their posters home about how they felt about that choice. What did you find?
“哦，那一定是我真正的感受。”我只是想到了我伴侣做过的那件非常烦人的事。也许事情并不像我想象的那么顺利。所以，那个众所周知的优缺点清单并不总是一件好事。在另一个实验中，你要求人们从展示的两张艺术海报中挑选一张，并允许他们带走选中的海报，但对于一半的志愿者，你只是到此为止，而对于另一半，你要求他们分析为什么选择那张海报，然后三周后，你调查了所有带海报回家的人对那个选择的感受。你发现了什么？
Well, again, I think common wisdom is that the people who made their choice thoughtfully by first-wasting pluses and minuses should be the ones who made a decision that they would end up liking the best. But again, we found the opposite. It was the group that just kind of went with their gut feelings without analyzing why that told us later that they really liked their poster. They were more apt to have put it up on their wall. And I think what happened to the reasons group is that they focused just on what was easy to put into words. And in the moment that we've come up with these reasons, we talk ourselves into this feeling,
嗯，同样，我认为常识是，那些通过先权衡优缺点而深思熟虑做出选择的人，应该是最终最喜欢那个决定的人。但同样，我们发现事实恰恰相反。那些只是凭直觉、没有分析原因的群体，后来告诉我们他们真的很喜欢他们的海报。他们更有可能把它挂在墙上。我认为理由组发生的情况是，他们只关注了容易用语言表达的东西。在我们想出这些理由的那一刻，我们说服自己产生了这种感觉，
oh, I must like this poster because I was able to put into words reasons why it was the best one. But that as time goes by, those reasons kind of fade. We're not thinking as much about exactly why we like it and our original feelings probably return. And so, you know, why did I choose this poster? It's really not very attractive now that I think about it.
“哦，我一定很喜欢这张海报，因为我能用语言表达出它是最好的理由。”但随着时间的推移，这些理由会逐渐消失。我们不再像以前那样思考为什么喜欢它，我们最初的感受可能会回归。所以，你知道，我为什么要选这张海报？现在想来，它其实并不怎么吸引人。
Your research on the barriers to self-knowledge has found that our efforts to know ourselves also are challenged by another obstacle. We commonly experience a failure of imagination when we try to predict how we'll feel in the future. Can you explain the idea of affective forecasting to me please? Sure. With my friend and colleague Daniel Gilbert, we've done a lot of research looking at how well people can predict their future feelings. And we find some systematic errors. I mean, first of all, let me say people aren't terrible at this. I mean, we know generally things that will make us happy
你关于自我认知障碍的研究发现，我们了解自己的努力也受到另一个障碍的挑战。当我们试图预测未来感受时，我们通常会经历想象力的失败。你能向我解释一下情感预测的概念吗？当然。我和我的朋友兼同事丹尼尔·吉尔伯特一起，做了很多研究，观察人们预测未来感受的能力。我们发现了一些系统性的错误。我的意思是，首先，让我说人们在这方面并不糟糕。我的意思是，我们通常知道什么会让我们快乐，
and things that will make us sad. But exactly how sad or how happy or how long that happiness or sadness will last. We do make mistakes. And we actually tend to think things will have more of an impact on us than they typically do. So back in 1980, Tim, I understand you had a very joyful experience that was connected
什么会让我们悲伤。但到底有多悲伤或多快乐，或者那种快乐或悲伤会持续多久，我们确实会犯错。而且我们实际上倾向于认为事情对我们的影响比它们通常的影响要大。所以回到1980年，蒂姆，我了解到你经历了一次非常快乐的经历，这与
with your hometown team winning the World Series. Tell me about that moment and how long you thought that feeling would last and how long it lasted. I am a long-suffering Philadelphia Phillies baseball fan having grown up in Philadelphia. For people who know their baseball, the Phillies went many, many years without winning the World Series. Until finally in 1980, they went all the way in one. Well, Lee, Philadelphia fillings of the World
你的家乡球队赢得世界大赛有关。告诉我那个时刻，你认为那种感觉会持续多久，以及它实际上持续了多久。作为一个在费城长大的费城费城人队棒球迷，我是一个长期受苦的球迷。对于了解棒球的人来说，费城人队很多很多年都没有赢得世界大赛。直到1980年，他们终于一路过关斩将赢得了冠军。
Champions. It's happening here in his fans. Everybody said we couldn't win. They said no, the fillings aren't good enough. They don't have heart. They don't have character. We have all of the above. Believe me.
这是费城人队的冠军。它发生在这里，在球迷中。每个人都说我们赢不了。他们说不，费城人队不够好。他们没有心。他们没有性格。我们拥有以上所有。相信我。
You see the K9 core in the backdrop. And I remember vividly watching the last game of the World Series in my living room with a good friend who had also grown up in Philadelphia and was an avid baseball fan. And once the final out was recorded, we were just speechless., how long did that happen this last? You know, when I thought about it over the next couple of days, it was pleasurable, but it's not like my life changed in any appreciable way. It certainly didn't last as long as I thought it might have. And this sort of return to an emotional baseline also happens with negative emotions as well,
你看到背景中的K9核心。我清楚地记得在客厅里和一位同样在费城长大、也是狂热棒球迷的好朋友一起观看世界大赛的最后一场比赛。当最后一个出局数被记录下来时，我们简直说不出话来。你知道，那种感觉持续了多久？当我在接下来的几天里回想它时，它是令人愉悦的，但我的生活并没有发生任何明显的改变。它肯定没有持续我可能认为的那么久。这种回归到情感基准线的情况在负面情绪中也会发生，
right? So negative events don't bother us as long as we might forecast that they will. Yeah, maybe even more so with negative events because we have this, what we've called a psychological immune system that is able to ward off negative events and recover from them quickly. Now, don't get me wrong. Painful things feel painful and when tragic things happen, it's awful. But the good news is that we have this psychological system that's able to reach some understanding of the event, find some meaning in it, and not think about it as long as we might anticipate. I understand that in your own life, Tim, you've lost both your parents, but also a brother. What were these events like when they happened, and how did they change over time? Well, like most people my age have experienced a lot of loss of family members and friends
对吧？所以负面事件并不会像我们预测的那样困扰我们那么久。是的，也许在负面事件中更是如此，因为我们拥有这种我们称之为“心理免疫系统”的东西，它能够抵御负面事件并从中迅速恢复。现在，别误会我的意思。痛苦的事情感觉很痛苦，当悲剧发生时，这很糟糕。但好消息是，我们拥有这种心理系统，能够对事件达成某种理解，找到某种意义，并且不会像我们预期的那样长时间地思考它。我了解到在你自己的生活中，蒂姆，你失去了双亲，也失去了一个兄弟。这些事件发生时是什么样的，它们随着时间的推移发生了怎样的变化？嗯，像大多数我这个年纪的人一样，我经历了很多家庭成员和朋友的离世，
in the last 10 years I lost both my parents. And, you know, as sad as it was, I was, I think I recovered, you know, fairly well from it. Both my parents lived long and happy lives. So it's something that when I think about, I'm able to feel sad, but life goes on. My brother's in other situation. his own life when he was 25 and that is a much more difficult event to try to come to terms with understand. And so, you know, I think it's fair to say that had a much longer impact on me. I think about it more. But even there, if you would ask me in advance of these tragedies, what will the lasting impact of them be? And this is what we find in our research,
在过去10年里，我失去了双亲。而且，你知道，虽然很悲伤，但我认为我从中恢复得相当好。我的父母都过着长寿而幸福的生活。所以当我想到它时，我能够感到悲伤，但生活还要继续。我兄弟的情况不同。他在25岁时去世，那是一个更难接受和理解的事件。所以，你知道，我认为公平地说，那对我产生了更长久的影响。我更多地想到它。但即使在那里，如果你在这些悲剧发生前问我，它们会有什么持久的影响？这就是我们在研究中发现的，
that the people tend to say they're going to agree for last much longer than it does. What is your theory, Tim, about why we have these gaps in self-knowledge when it comes to our preferences, when it comes to our forecasts? Why is it that our internal mechanisms, which most people imagine are very finely tuned to perceive reality accurately, why are they failing us? Well, there's also debate over this
人们倾向于说他们的悲伤会持续比实际长得多。蒂姆，关于为什么我们在偏好和预测方面存在这些自我认知差距，你的理论是什么？为什么我们的内部机制——大多数人认为它们是非常精细地调整以准确感知现实的——为什么它们会让我们失望？嗯，关于情感预测，也有争论。
with that fact of forecasting. There are some who argue that it can actually be functional to overestimate the impact of future events because it gets us out of bed in the morning and makes us work hard towards achieving the good things in life and avoiding the bad things. I think that may be part of it, but we have found the same kind of overestimation of impact
有些人认为，高估未来事件的影响实际上可能是有功能的，因为它让我们早上起床，让我们努力工作以实现生活中的美好事物并避免坏事。我认为这可能是其中的一部分，但我们发现了同样的影响高估，
even for events we can't control, like sporting events. Not everything's functional. I think our unconscious is our unconscious that's doing the work to reduce the impact of events. And by definition, we can't anticipate that in the future. We don't know what our unconscious is going to do. So it seems like I'll be thinking about that Philly's victory for weeks, not realizing that, well, you know, my mind will get back to normal much more quickly than I think. So you haven't just studied how introspection is in all that it's cracked up to be and the problems we have in self-knowledge. You've also studied what we can do about the problem.
即使对于我们无法控制的事件，比如体育赛事。并非一切都是有功能的。我认为是我们的潜意识在做功以减少事件的影响。根据定义，我们无法预见未来的情况。我们不知道我们的潜意识会做什么。所以看起来我会为费城人队的胜利思考几周，却没意识到，嗯，你知道，我的大脑会比我想象的更快恢复正常。所以你不仅研究了内省并非像人们吹嘘的那样，以及我们在自我认知中遇到的问题。你还研究了我们可以针对这个问题做些什么。
Now, I want to start with a story. When you and your wife go out to a restaurant, she look at the menu and then the two of you have what is by now a familiar conversation. Paying to picture of a time this recently happened to you and describe that conversation for me too. Well, I have to chuckle because I think each in our own way knows the other's preferences better than we do
现在，我想从一个故事开始。当你和妻子去餐馆时，她看菜单，然后你们俩进行了现在已经很熟悉的对话。描绘一下最近发生这种情况的时间，并为我描述那段对话，蒂姆。嗯，我不得不轻笑，因为我认为我们每个人都比对方更了解对方的偏好。
So in my wife's case I'm sure often look at the menu and She'll say something like oh here's a dish that looks interesting. It has a regular in it Maybe I'll order that and I say Honey, you've never liked a regular. I don't recall any time you've ever enjoyed a dish with a regular. Why don't you order a steak, which I know shall enjoy more. And I think in the end would admit.
所以在妻子的例子中，我肯定她经常看菜单，然后她会说类似“哦，这道菜看起来很有趣。里面有芝麻菜。也许我会点那个。”我说：“亲爱的，你从来都不喜欢芝麻菜。我不记得你什么时候喜欢过有芝麻菜的菜。你为什么不点牛排呢，我知道你会更喜欢。”我想最后她会承认。
But in fairness, I think the same is true of our, when we order a beer, which we like to do, she knows exactly what kind of beer she likes, a HZIPA, whereas I sometimes think, well, I like HZIPAs, but maybe I'll try a Pilsner tonight. She says, no, you're going to enjoy the HZIPA more and she's right. So I want to drill down on this just a minute because, yes, at one level, it seems intuitively obvious that people who are close to us would know us very well. But there actually are some really interesting psychological dimensions to it.
但公平地说，我认为当我们点啤酒时也是如此，我们喜欢这样做，她确切地知道她喜欢什么样的啤酒，比如HZIPA，而我有时会想，嗯，我喜欢HZIPA，但也许今晚我会尝试皮尔森啤酒。她说：“不，你会更喜欢HZIPA。”她是正确的。所以我想深入探讨一下这一点，因为，是的，在某种程度上，直觉上显而易见的是，亲近我们的人会非常了解我们。但实际上这其中有一些非常有趣的心理维度。
How is it that you know what she wants better than she does to? The people who know us well are good observers of our behavior and they can deduce from our actions what we like and what we don't. And sometimes, you know, we have theories ourselves that just go awry and don't match those preferences. So, you know, it's the people who are good observers of us who often can deduce our feelings better than we can. And of course, over the course of many meals, you've observed her facial expressions and non-verbal behaviors when she's ordered the arugula salad versus the steak, and she has observed your reactions when you are ordered different kinds of beer. Yes, and notices that the glasses still have fall by the end of the night. So in some ways, you know, when we think about people's opinions, we sort of imagine asking them their opinions for them to
你是怎么知道她想要什么，比她自己还清楚的，蒂姆？了解我们的人是很好的行为观察者，他们可以从我们的行动中推断出我们喜欢什么和不喜欢什么。有时，你知道，我们自己有一些理论，结果却偏离了那些偏好。所以，你知道，正是那些善于观察我们的人，往往能比我们自己更好地推断出我们的感受。当然，在多次用餐过程中，你观察过她点芝麻菜沙拉与牛排时的面部表情和非语言行为，她也观察过你点不同啤酒时的反应。是的，并注意到晚上结束时杯子里还有剩的。所以从某种意义上说，你知道，当我们思考人们的观点时，我们有点想象询问他们的观点让他们
tell us, but what you're pointing out is that there is, you know, what researchers might call non-verbal leakage here, where separate from whatever you're saying, you have other facial features, expressions, body language to communicate how you're feeling, and in some ways that might be at odds with what you're reporting verbally. Yes, now again I don't want to exaggerate this, I don't mean to say we're clueless about how we feel, but I do think there are times when we get it wrong and in those cases, you know, looking at how someone reacts on their face can be quite telling. We've seen how our friends can sometimes see us
告诉我们，但你指出的是，这里存在研究人员可能称之为“非语言泄露”的东西，除了你所说的任何话之外，你还有其他面部特征、表情、肢体语言来传达你的感受，在某些方面，这可能与你口头报告的内容不一致。是的，现在我不想夸大这一点，我并不是说我们对自己感觉如何一无所知，但我确实认为有些时候我们弄错了，在这些情况下，你知道，观察一个人的面部反应可以说明很多问题。我们已经看到我们的朋友有时能比我们自己
more clearly than we can see ourselves. They notice things about us. They can see things we might wish to ignore. But the most remarkable piece of evidence that others can know us more deeply than we can know ourselves comes from a study that asks people to assess their own personalities and the personalities of their friends. The study then linked this data to when the volunteers died.
更清楚地看到我们。他们注意到关于我们的事情。他们能看到我们可能希望忽略的事情。但关于他人能比我们自己更深刻地了解我们的最显著证据，来自于一项要求人们评估自己个性和朋友个性的研究。该研究随后将这些数据与志愿者去世的时间联系起来。
Well, this is a remarkable study. It looks at some data from the 1930s, in which they had a sample of people, and they had both the participants' ratings of their own personality. But they also had five friends' rate that person's personality. On the typical personality dimensions
嗯，这是一项了不起的研究。它查看了20世纪30年代的一些数据，当时他们有一个样本人群，他们既有参与者对自己个性的评分，也有五个朋友对该人个性的评分。在典型的个性维度上，
of how conscientious they were, how extroverted, how open to experience and so on. And because the study was done in the 1930s, they were curious as to, well, what predicted best how long the participants lived, their own ratings of their personality or their friends rating of their personality. Now, we've known for a while that some personality traits are linked with how long people live. People high in conscientiousness, for example, tend to have longer lives. The researchers looked at whether people described themselves as conscientious
比如他们有多尽责、多外向、多开放等。由于这项研究是在20世纪30年代进行的，他们很好奇，什么能最好地预测参与者能活多久：他们自己的个性评分，还是他们朋友的个性评分。现在，我们已经知道一段时间了，一些个性特征与人们的寿命有关。例如，尽责性高的人往往寿命更长。研究人员观察了人们是否将自己描述为尽责，
and whether their friends did so. And the friends out-predicted the participants themselves. Their ratings, particularly of their friends' conscientiousness, were a better predictor of how long people live than people's own ratings. So, in other words, personality ratings made by one's friends early in one's life accurately predicted 75 years in advance how long people would live. Yes, I mean, I think it's telling the country
以及他们的朋友是否这样认为。结果朋友的预测比参与者自己更准确。他们对朋友尽责性的评分，比人们自己的评分更能预测人们能活多久。所以，换句话说，朋友在一个人生命早期做出的个性评分，准确地预测了75年后人们能活多久。是的，我的意思是，我认为这说明了尽责性
interest is one of the best predictors because perhaps people who are as careful as attentive to their own health, more risk-taking are the ones who aren't going to live as well. To be clear, there are domains where we know more about ourselves than people who are close to us. Tim's point is not that our friends always know us better than we do. He's merely questioning the deeply held belief most of us have that we know ourselves better than anyone else can know us. I mean, we have so much unique information about ourselves. I mean, someone who didn't know I was a baseball fan would not be able to predict that on that
是最好的预测指标之一，因为也许那些对自己健康非常小心、细心、较少冒险的人，才是那些生活得更好的人。需要明确的是，在某些领域，我们比亲近我们的人更了解自己。蒂姆的观点并不是说我们的朋友总是比我们更了解我们。他只是在质疑我们大多数人深信不疑的信念，即我们比任何人都更了解自己。我的意思是，我们对自己拥有如此多独特的信息。我的意思是，一个不知道我是棒球迷的人，将无法预测在那
fateful night in 1980, I would be euphoric over the Phillies winning the World Series. But I think what we overestimate is how much our own knowledge can sometimes mislead us, that we're convinced we're in a good mood because of X, Y, or Z, when in fact that's not the case. We've seen how other people who are close friends and family can know things about us that we might not know about ourselves. But surely, that wouldn't be the case if those other people was strangers, right? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
1980年那个决定性的夜晚，我会因为费城人队赢得世界大赛而欣喜若狂。但我认为我们高估的是，我们自己的知识有时会如何误导我们，我们确信自己心情好是因为X、Y或Z，而事实上并非如此。我们已经看到，其他亲密的朋友和家人如何能知道一些关于我们的事情，而我们自己可能并不知道。但肯定，如果那些人是陌生人，情况就不会这样了，对吧？你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Tim Wilson is the author of the book, Strangers to Ourselves. His research finds when not very good at engaging in affective forecasting that is predicting how we will feel and what we will want in the future. Instead we often project how we are feeling now into the future. If we are unhappy now we imagine we will stay unhappy. If we are
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家蒂姆·威尔逊是《陌生人：我们自己》一书的作者。他的研究发现，我们不太擅长进行情感预测，即预测未来我们会感觉如何以及想要什么。相反，我们经常将现在的感受投射到未来。如果我们现在不快乐，我们想象我们会一直不快乐。如果我们
deliriously happy we think the feeling will last forever. Tim researchers have found a way for people to get a much better sense of how we think the feeling will last forever. Tim, researchers have found a way for people to get a much better sense of how they'll feel in the future, using a technique called surrogation. What is surrogation? Well, it's basically trusting how other people have reacted. So if I want to try to guess how I'll feel if some event occurs, people who have experienced that event are probably a pretty good source of information to at least act as a guide
欣喜若狂，我们认为这种感觉会永远持续下去。蒂姆，研究人员找到了一种方法，让人们能更好地感知未来会感觉如何，使用一种称为“替代法”的技术。什么是替代法？嗯，它基本上是信任他人的反应。所以如果我想尝试猜测如果发生某种事件我会感觉如何，那些经历过该事件的人可能是一个很好的信息来源，至少可以作为一个指南。
as to how I will feel. And in some ways this gets around the problem of imagination that we talked about earlier, which is that if we are not very good at imagining how we're going to feel in the future, in some ways this removes the element of imagination from judging how we might end up feeling. Yes, it basically hands over the problems that someone else was already experienced and said, well, they liked it. I guess maybe I would too. So Tim, you've investigated the effect of surrogation in a study with your colleague Dan Gilbert using speed data. Can you tell me about that study, please? The basic question was, who could predict best how much they would like a man in a speed date?
关于我会有什么感觉。在某种程度上，这绕过了我们之前讨论过的想象力问题，也就是说，如果我们不擅长想象未来会有什么感觉，那么在某种程度上，这消除了在判断我们最终会有什么感觉时所涉及的想象力因素。是的，它基本上把别人已经经历过的问题交给了我们，他们说，嗯，他们喜欢它。我想也许我也会喜欢。所以蒂姆，你和你的同事丹·吉尔伯特通过一项使用快速约会数据的研究调查了替代效应。你能告诉我关于那项研究的情况吗？基本的问题是，谁能最好地预测他们会在快速约会中有多喜欢一个男人？
could predict best how much they would like a man in a speed date. Those who were given a personal profile of the man, including his picture, or another group that was given no information about the guy, except they found out how one other woman had rights him after she had a speed date with him. That was the surrogation condition. I don't know anything about this guy except how one of the person felt. And then I have to predict how I would feel. And it turns out that we did a better job of knowing how they'd feel, of predicting how they'd feel, knowing how one other woman felt, did a better job of predicting how they'd feel. The ones that got us profile actually were somewhat surprised that sometimes they didn't like him as much as they thought they would, or maybe they liked him a little more
谁能最好地预测他们会在快速约会中有多喜欢一个男人。那些被给予该男人的个人资料（包括他的照片）的人，或者另一组没有得到关于该男人的任何信息的人，除了他们发现另一个女人在与他快速约会后是如何评价他的。那是替代条件。除了另一个人感觉如何之外，我对这个家伙一无所知。然后我必须预测我会有什么感觉。事实证明，我们能更好地了解他们会有什么感觉，预测他们会有什么感觉，知道另一个女人感觉如何，能更好地预测他们会有什么感觉。那些得到资料的人实际上有点惊讶，有时他们并不像他们想象的那样喜欢他，或者也许他们喜欢他多一点
than they thought they would, but the best guy was knowing how one other woman had felt about him. That's kind of remarkable that a stranger who knows nothing about me is better able to predict how I will enjoy a situation than I can myself. We may be underestimating how much sometimes we're all like in our preferences. We tend to like the same kind of movies. And for college women, we have similar impressions of another college man.
比他们想象的要多，但最好的方法是知道另一个女人对他有什么感觉。这真是太了不起了，一个对我一无所知的陌生人竟然比我自己更能预测我将如何享受某种情况。我们可能低估了我们在偏好上有多么相似。我们往往喜欢同类型的电影。对于大学女生来说，我们对另一个大学男生的印象是相似的。
And in those situations where there's not much very incententenium, it can be quite useful to know how somebody else felt. So I want to dive a little deeper into one of the ideas you just mentioned just now, Tim, which is that one reason we might not wish to engage in segregation is I might tell myself, look, it's true that other women may have, you know, impressions about this guy that are positive or negative, but ultimately, it's my impressions of him that really will determine whether I like him or not, because of course those other women are not like me. I'm different from them. Can you talk about this idea that it's the feeling of uniqueness, perhaps the illusion of uniqueness, that in some ways is behind part of our reticence to engage in surrogation. Yes, I mean, I do think we like to believe
在那些没有太多激励因素的情况下，了解别人的感受是非常有用的。所以我想深入探讨你刚才提到的一个想法，蒂姆，那就是我们可能不想进行替代的一个原因是我可能会告诉自己，看，其他女性可能对这个家伙有正面或负面的印象，这是真的，但最终，我对他的印象才真正决定我是否喜欢他，因为当然那些女性不像我。我和她们不同。你能谈谈这个想法吗，即这种独特感，也许是独特感的错觉，在某种程度上是我们不愿进行替代的部分原因。是的，我的意思是，我确实认为我们喜欢相信
that we have a unique reaction to the world, and we're not just like sheep reacting the same way. In another study, we actually gave people both kinds of information. We gave them surrogation information how one other person felt, or a description of this food item. And people went with a description and ignored how much someone else had felt, because as you said, I think that why is that relevant to me? I don't care what
我们对世界有独特的反应，我们不仅仅是像羊一样做出同样的反应。在另一项研究中，我们实际上给了人们两种信息。我们给了他们替代信息，即另一个人感觉如何，或者对这种食物的描述。人们选择了描述，而忽略了别人感觉如何，因为正如你所说，我想为什么这与我有关？我不关心
another person felt. This food sounds particularly delicious or not. But again, I think we underestimate how a lot of times there isn't as much variance in the opinion of the world as we think there is. Researches once set up an experiment where groups of customers at a microbrewery were offered different samples of beer. And it's an interesting study about the nature of Saragation Tim. Can you tell me what they found? They were looking at the phenomenon that when a group of people are at a restaurant,
另一个人感觉如何。这种食物听起来特别好吃还是不好吃。但同样，我认为我们低估了在很多情况下，世界上的观点并没有我们想象的那么大的差异。研究人员曾经做过一个实验，让一家精酿啤酒厂的顾客群体品尝不同的啤酒样本。这是一个关于替代本质的有趣研究，蒂姆。你能告诉我他们发现了什么吗？他们正在观察这样一种现象，即当一群人在餐馆时，
there's pressure to be unique and not order what someone else had ordered. It somehow just seems like we're not expressing our individuality if you just ordered the irregular salad and I really wanted that, but I don't want to lookity if you just ordered the arugula salad and I really wanted that but I don't want to look like I'm just copying you. So the researchers did a very clever study with beers actually where they presented people with beers in groups, the groups of customers. And in one condition they simulated the normal situation where each person took turns ordering
有一种要独特的压力，而不是点别人点的东西。如果我点了芝麻菜沙拉，而我真的很想要那个，但如果我不想看起来像是在模仿你，那么这似乎就不是在表达我们的个性。所以研究人员实际上做了一个非常聪明的啤酒研究，他们向成群的顾客展示了啤酒。在一种情况下，他们模拟了正常情况，即每个人轮流点
which beer they wanted. But in another condition, they had people just check off on a piece of paper, which one they wanted, without knowing what the other said checked. And in that condition, there was more overlap as to what people ordered. And people enjoyed the beer they got more. They were less likely to regret what they ordered. They got what they wanted more when they didn't have to worry about
他们想要的啤酒。但在另一种情况下，他们让人们在一张纸上勾选他们想要的啤酒，而不知道其他人勾选了什么。在这种情况下，人们点的东西有更多的重叠。而且人们更享受他们得到的啤酒。他们不太可能后悔自己点的东西。当他们不必担心
what other people had done. I remember speaking some time ago with Dan Gilbert who's at Harvard and at that university they have this system where students can essentially check out different professors in shopping week as it's I think, in the early part of the semester. And then doing some of these studies would always be more than the fact that students would say the only way for me to tell if I like this class is to actually sit in the class previously attended the entire semester with the professor thought about him or her. But no matter how much data you present to people, people prefer to actually sit on the class and make up their own minds, quote unquote, make up their own minds rather than rely
别人做了什么时，他们得到了他们想要的更多东西。我记得前段时间和哈佛大学的丹·吉尔伯特交谈过，在那所大学，他们有这样一个系统，学生们基本上可以在学期初的购物周查看不同的教授。然后做这些研究总是比学生们说的那样更让我惊讶，学生们说判断我是否喜欢这门课的唯一方法就是实际坐在课堂上，之前参加过整个学期教授的课程，思考过他或她。但无论你向人们提供多少数据，人们都更喜欢实际坐在课堂上并自己做决定，所谓的“自己做决定”，而不是依赖
on the information of targets. That's a great example. I mean, what we see through our own senses seems so much more compelling than hearing how one or the person felt, even though it's not always true. You know, the studies remind me of a story, and I'm not sure if the story is apocryphal, but in the early days of Netflix, when the streaming service was trying to determine what people would want to watch, Netflix would ask people, what kind of movie do you want to watch. Netflix would ask people, what kind of movie do you want to watch? And people would say, I want to watch the French documentary about the political causes
目标的信息。这是一个很好的例子。我的意思是，我们通过自己的感官所看到的东西似乎比听到另一个人感觉如何要令人信服得多，尽管这并不总是正确的。你知道，这些研究让我想起了一个故事，我不确定这个故事是否是杜撰的，但在Netflix的早期，当流媒体服务试图确定人们想看什么时，Netflix会问人们，你想看什么样的电影？人们会说，我想看关于导致二战的政治原因的法国纪录片
that led to World War II. But when the weekend rolled around, people would watch the same old romantic comedies and the latest version of the Fast and Furious, or the latest Jason Bourne movie, or just whatever was the easiest to consume. And after some time I think Netflix basically just stopped asking people what do you want to watch and built an algorithm that just paid attention to what people did, what movies they actually watched and what movies everybody else was watching. And I believe the algorithm right now is not really tuned at all to what we say our preferences are and is tuned almost entirely
但是当周末到来时，人们会看同样的旧浪漫喜剧和最新版本的《速度与激情》，或者最新的《谍影重重》，或者任何最容易消费的东西。过了一段时间，我想Netflix基本上停止问人们想看什么，并建立了一个算法，只关注人们做了什么，他们实际看了什么电影，以及其他人正在看什么电影。我相信现在的算法并没有真正针对我们所说的偏好进行调整，而是几乎完全针对
to the idea of surrogation. And I think this perhaps is a surrogation on a much larger scale, on the scale of thousands or millions of people, but I think it's fundamentally the same idea, which is that aggregating the information of large numbers of people around us might be better predictors to what we ourselves would like to watch on the weekend than simply asking us the question. Yeah, that's a great example. And I've always been curious as to how much in that algorithm does weight other people's opinion, but I suspect you're right that it's the weight is a lot. Yeah. Do you have the experience of basically Netflix putting things before you that you didn't think that you'd like and then you watch it and then you realize, oh yeah, I kind of like that movie too.
替代的想法。我认为这也许是一个更大规模的替代，在成千上万或数百万人规模上的替代，但我认为这从根本上是同一个想法，即汇总我们周围大量人的信息可能比简单地问我们问题更能预测我们自己周末想看什么。是的，这是一个很好的例子。我一直很好奇那个算法在多大程度上权衡了其他人的意见，但我怀疑你是对的，权重很大。是的，你有过Netflix基本上把你没想过会喜欢的电影放在你面前，然后你看了，然后你意识到，哦，是的，我也挺喜欢那部电影的经历吗？
Yeah, I think, you know, I have to say, like our own participants, I probably distrust the surrogation information more than I should there, I think, whatever they know. So your research has identified a number of ways that we can use surrogation effectively in our lives. And to begin with, one of the insights is that it might be useful to find not one, but several surrogates to consult. Why might this be the case? I think that tells us how much variance there is in the opinion. If three or four people all felt the same way about something, that is pretty
是的，我想，你知道，我不得不说，就像我们自己的参与者一样，我可能比我应该做的更不信任替代信息，我想，无论他们知道什么。所以你的研究已经确定了我们可以在生活中有效使用替代的多种方法。首先，见解之一是，寻找不止一个，而是几个替代者来咨询可能是有用的。为什么会这样？我认为这告诉我们意见有多大的差异。如果三四个人对某件事的感觉都一样，那是一个相当
strong guide that we're going to feel the same way. But if they were all over the map, that's a better indication that maybe I should trust my own opinions here. We talked earlier about the errors in our affective forecasting system and you told me about some of the losses you've experienced. Recently a graduate student of yours came to you in some distress. What did he tell you to? You know, quite sadly, this graduate student's brother had also taken his life. And, you know, I felt I was in a position to offer, obviously, my condolences, but also maybe it would help to tell him about my own experiences that as tragic as this is and as much as I still do think about it, the pain will receive, and maybe quicker than you think.
强有力的指南，表明我们会有同样的感觉。但如果他们各执一词，那是一个更好的迹象，表明也许我应该相信我自己的观点。我们之前谈到了我们情感预测系统中的错误，你告诉了我你经历过的一些损失。最近你的一名研究生带着一些痛苦来找你。他告诉你什么？你知道，非常令人难过的是，这名研究生的兄弟也自杀了。而且，你知道，我觉得我有能力提供，显然，我的慰问，但也可能告诉他我自己的经历会有所帮助，尽管这很悲惨，而且我仍然会想到它，痛苦会减轻，也许比你想象的要快。
To be honest, I'm not sure that kind of advice, registers, particularly when people are in the throes of grief, I'm not sure it helps to say you'll get over it, but I hope it was of some solace. It is interesting, of course, the point that you're just making, which is that at a moment of great emotion, some of us might actually resent hearing from people who've been through that experience before and have come through it on the other side. Because in some ways, especially if they no longer feel the same emotion with the same
老实说，我不确定那种建议在人们处于悲痛之中时是否特别有效，我不确定说你会克服它是否有帮助，但我希望这能带来一些安慰。当然，你刚才提到的观点很有趣，即在情绪激动的时刻，我们中的一些人实际上可能会怨恨听到那些以前经历过这种经历并从另一边走出来的人的话。因为在某种程度上，特别是如果他们不再以同样的
intensity, it somehow might feel like what they experienced is not as bad as what you're experiencing and so they shouldn't be telling you how you're going to feel in the future. Yes. And it's another reason I think we might hesitate to both reach out to others to get their opinions on what we're going through as well as volunteer our own experiences to others because of this gap. No, I think that's definitely true. That it somehow seems to trivialize our own feelings to have someone say, you're going
强度感受同样的情绪，这在某种程度上可能感觉他们所经历的并不像你正在经历的那么糟糕，所以他们不应该告诉你未来会有什么感觉。是的。我认为这是我们可能犹豫是否要向他人寻求他们对我们正在经历的事情的意见，以及向他人自愿分享我们自己的经历的另一个原因，因为这种差距。不，我认为这绝对是真的。让别人说“你会克服它的”，在某种程度上似乎贬低了我们自己的感受
to get over it and so one should be careful with such advice, I think. Something along the same lines happened with Tim and his friend Susan. He thought she was not in the right relationship. Others who knew Susan also felt like she was with the wrong guy. But most friends in these situations, at least in polite society, keep their opinions to themselves. Yes, and we probably know that it wouldn't go land terribly well with a person. I'm an avid reader of advice columns
所以我觉得这种建议应该小心。蒂姆和他的朋友苏珊也发生了类似的事情。他认为她没有处于正确的恋爱关系中。其他认识苏珊的人也觉得她和错误的人在一起。但在这些情况下，大多数朋友，至少在礼貌的社会中，会把自己的意见留给自己。是的，我们可能知道这在当事人那里不会有太好的结果。我是建议专栏的狂热读者
and a common theme in them is someone who says, I know my friend was with a wrong person. Should I tell them my son or my daughter, I can't stand their partner. And you know, it's, A, they wouldn't listen if you did tell, and B, it would ruin your relationship if you did. So people, I think, often are reluctant.
其中一个共同的主题是有人说，我知道我的朋友和错误的人在一起。我应该告诉他们吗？我的儿子或女儿，我无法忍受他们的伴侣。你知道，A，如果你告诉他们，他们不会听，B，如果你告诉他们，会破坏你们的关系。所以我认为人们往往很勉强。
So you've sometimes suggested that they should be a new hallmark holiday that could encourage surrogation. Tell me about this idea too. Well, when I teach my seminars on this topic, I often propose to the students of, you know, why wouldn't we want to get this information in a helpful way? So what if there were a new hallmark holiday called social feedback holiday, where you get cards from your friends with useful feedback. Now, they have to be some ground rules. Your friends would have to be kind and maybe give you advice about something that's controllable so that you can change. So, you know, telling you,
所以你有时建议应该有一个新的霍尔马克节日，可以鼓励替代。也告诉我这个想法。嗯，当我教授关于这个主题的研讨会时，我经常向学生们提出，你知道，为什么我们不想以有益的方式获得这些信息呢？那么，如果有一个新的霍尔马克节日叫“社交反馈节”会怎样，在那里你会收到朋友们发来的带有有用反馈的卡片。现在，必须有一些基本规则。你的朋友必须友善，也许给你一些关于可控事情的建议，这样你就可以改变。所以，你知道，告诉你，
you know, lately you've been interrupting people in conversations too much or we notice that you don't seem happy in this relationship. And these were not, you know, when the mail arrived and we got a bunch of cards, it wouldn't be easy to read them. But if there was unanimity, all our friends were looking at the same thing,
你知道，最近你在谈话中打断别人太多了，或者我们注意到你在这个关系中似乎不快乐。这些不是，你知道，当邮件到达我们收到一堆卡片时，阅读它们并不容易。但如果有一致意见，我们所有的朋友都在看同样的事情，
saying, dump that part. That's something we maybe should take seriously. I have to ask you, have you, did your students embrace that? Do your students send each other home on cards with social feedback? I can just imagine all kinds of ways that could go wrong, to be honest. You know, I think in all the years I've proposed that in my classes, not one person has said they think it's a good idea. They look at me in horror, you know, as if you mean we're actually supposed to receive
说，甩掉那个伴侣。那可能是我们应该认真对待的事情。我必须问你，你有，你的学生接受了吗？你的学生会互相寄送带有社交反馈的卡片吗？老实说，我可以想象所有可能出错的方式。你知道，我认为在我课堂上提出这个建议的所有年头里，没有一个人说他们认为这是一个好主意。他们惊恐地看着我，你知道，好像你是说我们真的应该收到
this anonymous feedback about all our flaws, that would be terrible. And I think, well, but if the things you can correct easily, wouldn't the world be a better place if everyone's flaws were corrected through my hallmarked days? Well, I have failed to convince people. You know, the interesting thing here, Tim, is it's not just that people are sometimes reluctant to share negative feedback with us, they might also be reluctant to share positive feedback to us, just because they believe that there are certain bounds
这种关于我们所有缺点的匿名反馈，那太可怕了。我想，嗯，但如果这些事情你可以轻易纠正，如果每个人的缺点都通过我的霍尔马克节日得到纠正，世界不是会变得更美好吗？嗯，我没能说服人们。你知道，这里有趣的是，蒂姆，不仅仅是人们有时不愿意与我们分享负面反馈，他们也可能不愿意与我们分享正面反馈，仅仅是因为他们认为存在某些
of propriety that should be respected, certain boundaries that should be respected. And you yourself had an experience of this, of someone who was close to you being reluctant to share feedback with you. This was many years ago. Could you tell us about the time in your early 20s when you introduced your parents to a girl whom you were dating? Paint a picture for me of the moment if you would. No, I had been seeing this particular person for probably about a year.
应该尊重的礼仪界限，应该尊重的某些界限。你自己也有过这样的经历，你亲近的人不愿意与你分享反馈。这是多年前的事了。你能告诉我们你在20岁出头时把你的父母介绍给你正在约会的女孩的那次经历吗？如果你愿意，请为我描绘一下那一刻的画面。不，我当时和这个特定的人交往大概有一年了。
It was during the summer when I took her with me on a vacation with my parents, and we spent a few days with them. And I found out later that my father, after this visit, had written a letter to a very good friend of his, updating him on what was going on. And he said, in this letter,
那是在夏天，我带她和我父母一起去度假，我们和他们待了几天。后来我发现，这次访问后，我父亲写了一封信给他的一位好朋友，向他通报了正在发生的事情。他在信中说，
he said, oh, by the was going on. And he said, in this letter, he said, oh, by the way, Tim brought a new girlfriend, and she just seems to me to be the ideal partner for him. This is your father telling his friend? Yes. And he mentioned to my mother that he had said this, and my mother said, well, why are you telling your friends and not Tim? Wouldn't this be something the Tim should hear? And so my father called me up a week or two right, and he was kind of embarrassed.
他说，哦，顺便说一句，蒂姆带了一个新女朋友，她在我看来是他理想的伴侣。这是你父亲告诉他的朋友吗？是的。他向我母亲提到他说了这些，我母亲说，嗯，你为什么要告诉你的朋友而不是蒂姆？这难道不是蒂姆应该听到的吗？所以我的父亲在一两周后给我打了电话，他有点尴尬。
And he said, well, you know, we don't usually talk about these things that much, but your mother thinks I should tell you that I really liked your girlfriend. And I thought she would be the ideal partner. And maybe because we didn't talk about these things that much, it had a real impact on me. Now, I should say that it's not like I had huge doubts about this relationship, because in fact,
他说，嗯，你知道，我们通常不怎么谈论这些事情，但我母亲认为我应该告诉你，我真的很喜欢你的女朋友。我觉得她会是理想的伴侣。也许因为我们不怎么谈论这些事情，它对我产生了真正的影响。现在，我应该说，并不是说我对这段关系有巨大的怀疑，因为事实上，
the woman I was seeing ended up being my wife, and we've been together for over 40 years. So my father was right. Tim Wilson is a social psychologist at the University of Virginia. He's the author of the book, Stranger's to Ourselves, discovering the adaptive unconscious. Tim, thank you for talking to me today on Hidden Brain. It's great to be here, thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy,
我当时交往的那个女人最终成了我的妻子，我们在一起已经超过40年了。所以我父亲是对的。蒂姆·威尔逊是弗吉尼亚大学的社会心理学家。他是《陌生人：发现适应性潜意识》一书的作者。蒂姆，谢谢你今天在《隐藏的大脑》上与我交谈。很高兴来到这里，谢谢你的邀请。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡，
Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Io-OT. Io is a social impact editor at Spotify. Io recently helped us to create a playlist with some of our favorite episodes from Hidden Brain and other shows, looking at how we can build better relationships. You can find that playlist and Spotify's Play or Part category. Thanks so much, Aya. Next week, in our YouTube.io series, how we can use the Brain's visual system to boost our motivation, achieve goals, and gain perspective. So there's great power in what it is that we see,
安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是Io-OT。Io是Spotify的社会影响编辑。Io最近帮助我们创建了一个播放列表，其中包含我们最喜欢的一些来自《隐藏的大脑》和其他节目的剧集，探讨我们如何建立更好的关系。你可以在Spotify的“播放或部分”类别中找到该播放列表。非常感谢，Aya。下周，在我们的YouTube.io系列中，我们将探讨如何利用大脑的视觉系统来增强我们的动力、实现目标并获得视角。所以我们所看到的东西有巨大的力量，
which is why a piece of advice that I offer is to schedule into our calendar those things that we might not think weren't scheduling. If you're a supporter of our work, thank you. It really does mean the world to us. If you are not supporting us as yet, but like our work and find it useful, please help us to produce more shows like this.
这就是为什么我提供的一条建议是将那些我们可能认为不值得安排的事情安排到我们的日历中。如果你是我们工作的支持者，谢谢你。这对我们来说真的意味着全世界。如果你还没有支持我们，但喜欢我们的工作并觉得它有用，请帮助我们制作更多像这样的节目。
Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, support the show you love by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
前往support.hiddenbrain.org。再次重申，通过访问support.hiddenbrain.org来支持你喜爱的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹坦。很快再见。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。